mark said you and tana were practicing
that kiss on your own time
so we did we did practice the kids on
our own time you have to it's awkward
the first time in front of everybody so
we were like okay we gotta get out of
the way let's just do it
okay let's just soak it in your
billboards are on faces all over
hollywood baby how you feeling i feel
crazy
i feel so excited and so grateful and um
yeah i don't know it's so hard i'm like
speechless 99 of the time has it sunk
into your head though that you are
starring in a major motion picture
you're kind of serving marilyn monroe
vibes tonight thank you oh my gosh thank
you that means a lot no it's crazy um
this opportunity was obviously so
incredible and i'm so so so thankful for
the cast the crew the production the
everyone that's really had a part in
this coming to life it's it's really
surreal
makeovers are my thing when i first met
him he was 120 pounds of bad hair why
don't you just make another jordan i
will create the next prom king are you
going to the met gala that's for me to
know and you to find out i saw a rumor
you're sitting next to beyonce oh my
gosh yeah i'm sitting next to beyonce
let's keep that going pretend that's
happening yeah well who is your date
tonight my date tonight uh you are my
date tonight i'll take it i'll take it
okay we're wondering what is it omer
what does he think of the movie yeah he
likes it i think he i mean he hasn't
seen it yet so hopefully he'll be able
to watch it and give me his opinion so
you guys are having fun together yeah
having lots of fun i'm having so much
fun all today so lots more fun to come
by the way in the movie you know your
character it's very much based on she
has this viral moment that goes wrong
and that's the the catalyst for
everything have you ever been afraid of
having such a moment like do you think
about do you think before you post and
what would you do if that moment
happened um i don't think about it too
often but i will say yesterday i went
live on instagram and i tripped over a
box in my apartment and i like actually
fell and i was so embarrassed so that
happened i was like oh
and then i kind of had to carry on it
happens
carry on yeah women we're all human
breakups are hard i was humiliated
you're going viral in the wrong way it
will get better you've got a big
birthday coming up 21. yeah oh 21. i'm
scared you are why i don't know it's so
weird because my mom had me when she was
21. so then i'm like oh my gosh i'm
having a crisis i'm like it's so weird
we're living so such different lives but
no i'm excited for 21 i'll hopefully
have lots of fun how are you gonna
celebrate it's a big birthday goodness i
don't know um i'm sure i'll go to vegas
because everyone does that um new
orleans
that would be a good one for when i'm 21
yeah so i was talking to the director
and he was telling me that man you put
the work in you learned to act for this
movie you hustled and he was so inspired
by it where do you want to go from here
is it more movies do you have more music
coming out uh definitely want to keep on
going with the movies i'm very excited
for that um lots of new exciting things
coming up but not too much that i can
talk about yet um but it's all going to
be really exciting and hopefully kind of
going to surprise a lot of people oh you
already surprised us with this what's
next who knows dad okay you've done
movies music what's next broadway
i mean hey
never say never courtney in the movie
making her debut and i remember you told
me at our junket interview she is kind
of that that mentor for you in real life
have you talked to her today has she
sent any good vibes your ways you hit
the carpet yes she is the very best like
i always say she's an incredible friend
and um was super excited we kind of like
talked about doing something together
for it but then it ended up not being
able to work out but it's okay i'll see
her soon who's the new guy a little
scruffy but cute
just wait until i'm done with his
makeover so in all those acting lessons
what's something you walked away with
that you'll remember that you learned
about acting on this movie i think just
finding
relationships on set that like you can
kind of use to inspire the characters
too and just have genuine connections to
your own character too i feel like
that's something i've learned a lot and
like really am inspired by the other
people that were on the set and really
like
got into the character in and outside of
filming which is something that i think
is really important too i think mark
said you and tana were practicing that
kiss on your own time
we did we did practice the kids on our
own time you have to it's awkward the
first time in front of everybody so we
were like okay we gotta get out of the
way let's just do it he's definitely not
what i expected
[Music]